I had to use one of them there's only
one left there's only one left there
can't just be one left what the hell are
we gonna do now
oh it's fine it was foolish thinking I
could escape but Zoe go both of you just
go come with us I'm sure there's someone
who can help this is my home apparently
I belong you I'll send help don't bother
there won't be anyone left to help
[Music]
Ethan
you made it
I'm glad
did I
[Music]
they say that when one door closes
another opens well a door closed tonight
and what a long night it was but not
just for me me and I weren't the only
victims here so were the Baker's it was
that thing Evelyn who made them that way
[Music]
but now I've a lens dead and these guys
are here to clean up the mess
I just come to terms with losing me and
now she's back and wants to start over
put all this behind us
maybe this is where the next door opens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I really am but Saul you'll be
able to guide the two of us to safety
and then I can come back for you go I
don't want to hear it both of you just
go go my place is here with her don't be
ridiculous you forget I still have a job
to do
I'll send help
I cannot wait to be done with this
babysitting job I won't my loving
husband
i miss you
ah I gotta get back to work I love you
either I miss you so much i'm sending
tons of kisses bye baby good bye
they say that when one door closes
another opens well a door closed tonight
and what a long night it was but not
just for me me and I weren't the only
victims here so were the Baker's it was
that thing Evelyn who made them that way
but now I've a win's dead
and these guys are here to clean up the
mess
I had just come to terms with losing me
of the first time but now I've lost her
again
[Music]
and the only other door I can see is
closed
[Music]
you